طاولة ضخمة مستديرة وعلى طرفه
بتلك الزاوية الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون. مهلا مهلا مهلا. لنعد
الزمن الى الخلف قليلا. الا
تتذكرون تلك الطاولة الطويلة
التي وضع بوتين عليها ماكرون. ها
هي الصين اليوم تطبق الدرس
الروسي في اذلال الفتى الفرنسي.
وبكل اختصار زوجان متخاصمان.
وهنا نقصد امريكا واوروبا
والمأذون هي الصين التي ستعلن
الطلاق. وذاك الطفل الشقي
وماكرون. هذا هو الوضع الحالي
بكل اختصار. فهل ستكون فرنسا هي
سبب الطلاق بين امريكا واوروبا?
الصين بتلك الزاوية تضحك. وروسيا
تضع يدها على كتفها. نعم. امريكا
واوروبا ارسلت الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون كرسول محذرا الصين. ظنا
منهم ان الصين سترتجف من الخوف
وتترك الروسية اصحاب العيون
الضيقة قرأوا تعويدتهم في ادان
ماكرون. ليعود ويصبح جيفار
اوروبا معلنا عن مطلب الاستقلال
الاستراتيجي وان الصين مستعدة
لان تدعم اوروبا لتحصل على
استقلال عالمي بدلا من بقائهم
يدورون في الفلك الامريكي. هنا
تظهر الحكمة الصينية وللقصة
بقية. امريكا تطلق الرصاص على
الطائرة الفرنسية تداعب الاراضي
الصينية معلنة وصول رسول بايدن
وما على الرسول الا البلاغ.
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
ورئيسة المفوضية الاوروبية يصلان
برسالتهما والتي تفوح منها رائحة
التهديد الامريكي والتي يتوعد
فيها البيت الابيض الصين بانها
اذا لم تتوقف عن مناوراتها
العسكرية عقب حينيتها عن احتلال
تايوان ايضا عن دعم الدب الروسي
في حروبه ضد الغرب فان بكين
ستواجه التحالف الامريكي
الاوروبي العسكري وسيكون مصيرها
اسوأ بكثير مما تتوقع. عندما
تذهب امريكا لاي عراك دولي او
سياسي لا بد ان تلوح بالعصا
الاوروبي. ولكن يبدو ان واشنطن
لا تعلم ان الحكيم الصيني سيكسر
العصا الامريكي دون ان يتحرك من
مكانه الصين تعلم جيدا ان ذاك
الفتى الفرنسي يطمح لقيادة
اوروبا ولم يتكيف مع العباءة
الامريكية. يهمس لماكون ويقولها
عن قر. دعك من الرسالة
الامريكية. وهيا لنداعب احلامك.
اعطته الصين درسا عن كيفية
الخروج من دائرة الصراع
الامريكية وفوائده. وامام
الصحافة العالمية. ماكون يصدم
ابناء العمص وقالها على الملأ.
يتعين على اوروبا تقليل اعتمادها
على الولايات المتحدة. وان تتجنب
الانجرار الى مواجهة الصين بشأن
تايوان. معلنا بذلك تخلي بلاده
عن الوقوف خلف امريكا بل ولم
يكتفي بذلك ليحرض اوروبا كلها
بعدم دعم الولايات المتحدة في
معركتها ضد الصين. وطالب الدول
الاوروبية بتقليص الاعتماد على
الدول الامريكي في معاملاتها
التجارية وكانه يدعو القارة
العجوز للتحالف من اجل اسقاط
الغول الامريكي ولم يكتف الرئيس
الفرنسي بذلك ايضا. بل هاجم
امريكا علنا وحملها مسؤولية
الازمات الاوروبية قائلا. الخطر
الكبير الذي تواجهه اوروبا اليوم
هو انها علقت في ازمات ليست من
شأنها. فماذا استفدنا? واضاف
ماذا يمنع من بناء استقلاليتنا
الاستراتيجية خارج امريكا. ما
زالت تصريحات الرئيس الفرنسي على
رؤوس الامريكان كالصاعقة واصبح
لسان حالهم يقول. يا الهي ماذا
يحدث؟ لقد ارسلناك لتهدد الصين
ونستعرض عضلاتنا امامها. فتهددنا
وانت تقف على الاراضي الصينية.
ماذا حدث يا ماكرون؟ كانت الصدمة
شديدة على مسؤولي البيت الابيض
لكن يظل السؤال ما هي كلمة السر
التي استغلتها الصين لتقلب الفتى
الفرنسي وقلبوا بها ايضا حال
امريكا رأسا على عقب. الهجمة
الصينية المرتدة. كان الرئيس
الصيني شي جين بينغ على علم كامل
برسالة التهديد الامريكي. ولكن
لم تكن واشنطن تعلم ان الصين
ستوجه لها صفعة قوية وبنفس
سلاحها فبعد ابلاغ ماكرون ورئيسة
الاوروبية الرئيس الصيني بفحوى
الرسالة الامريكية. فوجئوا به
يحدثهم عن استقلال دول اوروبا
الاستراتيجي وان مكان اوروبا
الصحيح هو قيادة العالم بعد ان
تقلص دورها كثيرا منذ نهاية
الحرب العالمية الثانية وتسليمها
شارة القيادة للولايات المتحدة.
واكد لهم ان الصين مستعدة لان
تدعم اوروبا في كافة المجالات من
اجل الحصول على من الوصاية
الامريكية وان تصبح قطبا اساسيا
له دور مؤثر على الساحة الدولية.
وان تخدم اوروبا مصالحها بعيدا
عن اوامر واشنطن ليقبل ماكون
العرض الصيني وينقلب على واشنطن
قبل حتى ان يغادر الصين. وسط
صدمة وذهول الجميع ما عدا الرئيس
الصيني الذي كان يعرف ما دار
وراء الكواليس. ولكن لماذا قدم
شي هذا وما سر ثقته الكبيرة بان
ماكغون سيقبله وينقلب على امريكا
بهذه السرعة. ذراع امريكا
المؤلم. كان شي جين بينغ يعلم
جيدا ان ماكون يحلم منذ وقت طويل
بالخروج من عباءة الولايات
المتحدة. وان تتوحد القوى
الاوروبية كلها تحت قيادته كما
لو كان يطمح باستعادة امجاد
نابليون بونابرت. ولكن هذه المرة
نابليون الجديد هيمنة واطماع
واشنطن والانانية الامريكية التي
لا ترى بعينيها الا مصلحتها فقط
حتى وان اراقت في سبيلها دماء
الابرياء. لذا فان عرض الرئيس
الصيني على ماكهون استطاع به
التنين الاسيوي الامساك بامريكا
من الذراع الذي يؤلمها. فخروج
اوروبا من عباءة واشنطن يعني
فقدان امريكا لاكثر من نصف قوتها
خصوصا قوة الاقتصادية. كما انها
ستفقد تأييد المجتمع الدولي
لقراراتها العنترية التي تعد
اوروبا الداعمة الرئيسي لها
والوقود الذي يغذي الترسانة
الامريكية. كل هذا دار بخلد
الصين قبل ان تقدم افضل عرض
لماكون بل ولاوربا كلها. وليس
بعيدا ان يكون الامر بدعم من
الدب الروسي. ليقلب التنين
الصيني الطاولة في وجه الغول
الامريكي. ويقتله نفس الرصاصة
التي اطلقها عليه فيا لخطورتكم
يا اصحاب العيون الضيقة. والمدهش
في الامر ان التنين الصيني
استطاع ان يدير الامور بما يخدم
مصالحه فقد انتهت الزيارة
بموافقة الرئيس الفرنسي على
العرض المغري. رغم الاهانة التي
تعرض لها في الصين. فما هي
الاهانة التي تعرض لها ماكون على
يد الصينيين? الملاكمة السياسية.
لعل تندهش من وجود علاقة بين
رياضة الملاكمة العنيفة ومصالح
الدول السياسية. ولكن كانت هذه
هي العلاقة الحقيقية بين فرنسا
والولايات المتحدة منذ سنوات
عديدة. فقد كان كلاهما يوجه
اللكمات للاخر بينما تقف اوروبا
تشاهد المباراة وتنتظر لتعرف من
منهما سيسقط اولا. فماكرون يرى
ان امريكا تقود اوروبا معصوبة
العينين. وتستنزف ثرواتها
وخبرتها من اجل تحقيق مصالحها هي
فقط. وان اوروبا لا تستفيد اي
شيء من السير وراء طموحات واطماع
ابناء العمسا. وحدث في عهد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب ان طلب ايمانويل ماكرون
المجتمع الاوروبي علنا بانشاء
منظومة دفاع مشترك تقتصر على
الدول الاوروبية فقط. والعمل على
الاستقلال الاستراتيجي لدول
القارة والخروج من محيط اوامر
واشنطن. وان على اوروبا ان توقف
دعمها للقرارات الامريكية وان
تتعامل بما يخدم مصالحها هي وليس
مصالح امريكا. لترد واشنطن
اللكمة بتجاهل الرأي الاوروبي
تماما في انسحاب قواتها من
افغانستان. فقد قامت امريكا بسحب
قواتها من افغانستان بقرار احادي
دون ان تستشير الدول الاوروبية
او حتى تنظر الى رأيها بعد ذلك.
ولم تكن تلك هي اللكمة الوحيدة
التي وجهتها واشنطن لباريس. ففي
عام الفين وستة عشر كانت فرنسا
قد ابرمت صفقة تقضي بان تبيع
لاستراليا مجموعة من الغواصات
البحرية. كانت قيمة الصفقة خمسين
مليار يورو. ولكن قبل ان يتم كل
شيء قفزت كل من امريكا وبريطانيا
للاستيلاء على الصفقة لصالحهما.
ويمنعان باريس من الحصول على اي
منفعة ما لن ينساه الفرنسيون
للامريكان. كان هذا جزءا يسيرا
من مظاهر وجولات العداء الفرنسي
الامريكي ولا احد يعلم الى ماذا
سينتهي هذا العداء? والان هل ترى
ان امريكا ستخرج من كل تلك
المعارك منتصرة? ام ان اصحاب
العيون الضيقة والدب الروسي
سيصنعون نظاما عالميا جديدا?